[Music]
the world-famous improv
[Applause]
keep your table conversations to
minimums alas the fleece
[Music]
[Applause]
because of the stage she knows from the
doll yes please welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
better than better than that y'all
better than that you're all most of
you're better than that so hi my dear
yeah we're close to LA you guys should
be over the Gary thing where we're like
neighbor like pals and you don't do that
to a pal do you do this to pal Dave pick
up the [ __ ] microphone let's start
the show it's not the drive that's
awesome it's the view you do see a lot
of cool stuff on the drive out here 405
well the view like to say we're two
hours away from LA I like to say we're
fourteen Home Depot's fourteen Humpty
bows away from home that's how I like to
say it it's really great
that's how those are my measuring sticks
you get down here and you're like [ __ ]
Irvine is beautiful I can't even tell if
he's being sarcastic I don't know look
you guys have all these different
colored malls it isn't I will say as far
as malls go get really good ball you got
it guys are not [ __ ] around yeah I
mean this balls so good that The Improv
was like well just go another part yeah
The Improv was literally like we're
moving like we're like we're the PF
Changs was and they're gonna come over
here
and then we're moving that Pinkberry and
then the ninth quadrant all right so you
got I tell your local stuff I just
really hate them all that's it yeah
nine people popping that's things I went
well this will wrap up the show it's
like Nick Carter's are you doing your
local stuff Carter's yeah oh yeah my
summer outfits it's Kurt what is
Carter's it's not a restaurant anymore
I'm learning it's a it's clothing for
very small children they're my colors do
you know I mean a lot of my colors are
in there I think I speak for everyone
when I say we would love to all as a
group go over there after the show and
put you as a baby stuff consider it done
hey hey so everyone heard entity any
Kaufman used to buy milk and cookies
well just we get to put you in diapers I
got his I get diaper it up
yeah and then I ride the ferris wheel
yeah Jesus listen I just got a lot
better keep pitching Dave nobody stop
him he's not fire should we mention that
there's no show in San Jose sure
animating The Improv there's no show
they didn't have another mall to move to
so they're gonna all away from the show
yeah so there's no show in San Diego
people know San Jose San Diego tomorrow
night
that's right that's right we're still
without all the sands doing one of them
it's 81 Home Depot's away right there
take a train they got a train that goes
down there an interesting story it was
at the end there Dave thank you
oh yes so if you if you are in San Jose
and you bought tickets you gotta call
The Improv reach out to the Improv to
get your money back mm-hmm that's that's
why we leave they're going to take the
money they made here tonight and they're
gonna pay him back up there too Oh
[ __ ] scam the guy yeah it's fraud
it's fraud it's direct fraud and we
don't mind calling them out we're the
only ones they don't call it the Fendi
then perhaps operate fraud
[Applause]
do you wanna say anything your show
dates gonna make what is this this week
oh well then I'll be in Madison
Wisconsin this Saturday August 24th I'll
be taping my album to shows comedy on
state come on out huh
the big important thing yeah the comedy
Bar Mitzvah that's what they say
and then and then you walk out station
you go I got it right a whole new hour
well I'm not I mean I think one's good
any one will do one my life one life
gonna make one record again that's it
I'm gonna be like one of those guys it
goes on the road and still this is the
same [ __ ] like 20 years from now I was
like this sucks I'll be like ah you
bought a ticket [ __ ] all new cuz I
said it in reverse order oh you should
actually just record in like five years
of court the same album and just call it
you bought a ticket [ __ ] say this is
a new album and then at the beginning of
the new bidat there's one new bit and
it's about how it's not a new hour
that's how you make fans isn't it yeah
you don't betray them constantly which I
have betray your fans
is anybody here doesn't know what
they're here to see we just came for
comedy and then you stumbled in and
you're like what the all right so you
made what is known as a mistake okay the
food's great put this guy baby clothes
it's a V so tolerate the show we're
gonna draw a line there there's nothing
sexual about it no no it is all for me
though for me it's sexual when I hear
you do that to someone who doesn't know
what's going on that's my fetish that's
what turns my [ __ ] prank so I'm like
yeah but you do that to a stranger I'm
like oh that's the only thing that gets
me up now and then go to my YouTube
channel I made a boom-boom
there's tons of videos just be saying it
to ladies yeah yep
literally what you would make the best
living you've ever made it though you
realize that right that's where we're at
now
I would absolutely have like 2 million
subscribers and people just begged it I
can watch this over and over again this
guy just goes at the women I feel like
you're getting dumped oh I'm an idiot
now but I mean this guy I love him look
at him she doesn't know what he's
talking about
you're listening to the dollar
[Applause]
this is a bisexual American history
where each week I wear pants a man with
a face and two feet Dave Anthony reads a
story from American history to his
friend Gareth Reynolds who has no idea
what the topic is going to be about you
walk outside this guy without a face and
you're like alright I get it I could not
relate to one of those hosts the hell
was he talking about February 16th 1953
our Lord Jesus Christ Christopher John
Boyce was born in Santa Monica
California it's great one person
clapping to really hit you guys hard the
local flavor for you who clap twice
while he's pinned there once I was what
I'm guessing there's literally no one in
Santa Monica who goes that's what that
means no he was raised with his eight
siblings in Palos Verdes and affluent
coastal town near Los Angeles when he
was young Chris developed a
black-and-white moral code that combined
his mother's devout Catholicism with his
father's strict conservatism so for you
who just walked in little things will
pop up early where I'll be like that's
important and what they've just said is
crucially important this person will be
psychotic there
no doubt classmates joke that he would
be the first American Pope
what a fun wrasse people say Catholic
school sucks sounds pretty fun could be
the next pope stop it puppy in the
middle oh dude you're so [ __ ]
Catholic no I'm not it will not be the
Pope stop act do it back my books a
teacher at his school would say quote
I've never known a boy with such
idealism good have a super super that's
not super not interpretive
eight-year-old is awesome yeah
I'm not being like wow holy [ __ ] I wear
this all the time he's crazy when he was
14 he became friends with a 21 year old
man who stopped there we've all seen it
a couple of times you like that's not
okay I don't like I'm not even saying it
anything weird but it's just like a 21
year olds like we get along real good
it's like you should not be with him
that's not okay it's not bro a little
Jimmy hey I don't get what's happening
in our dynamic
thanks my cigarettes well what a man
can't hang out with a fourteen-year-old
oh oh no oh that's interesting to hear
I didn't know that we're 21 year old man
who had waist-length hair drove a VW van
I'm starting to retract my flag I throw
on the plan like I didn't know he had
all that going for him and the falcon
named mohammed
[Applause]
boy hey man what are you thinking about
naming your father by Mohammed I think
this kid might be the next pope this
guy's Mohammed surrounded myself at the
right people right now it's a circle so
I like to call it cell if I'm being on I
won't get into this I won't do it
Chris Chris lovebirds so great match
sure he was super into falconry also yes
where the parents they around they died
over there then what if my if my kid
he's ten now but if in like four years
he comes up to me he's like hey man I
met a guy in a van who has a falcon
[Music]
[Applause]
listen to me
do not talk to strangers but you go with
that man you belladonna you understand
me
he's awesome the two friends smoked a
lot of weed together this is not what
you would want super Chris decided the
Vatican was quote just another selfish
political power center wrapped in jewels
hypocrisy and ritual someone has been
smoking weed
try to smoke it what are you let him fly
in the band
hey he was here before you [ __ ]
give him some of my hair to chew on he
loves that game I've got tons of it dude
who US atrocities in Vietnam Chris had
quote rejected nationalism as a
fundamental evil of mankind I am trying
to get a read on where this kid is
that's just it's not good I know that
it's great is it talking about a hero so
so a couple years after he met his
friend its soul mate its soul mate wait
he did but I took it out cuz there's so
many names okay good it's good good note
so around that time when he got
disillusioned by Vietnam his 21 year old
friend burnt to death when he hash hash
oil he was making caught fire
you could see that coming a mile away
this guy was 100% gonna die in a hash
fire minute we met him just the birds
flying around is it safe to say he died
doing what he loves his last words where
I'm so baked look so weird Chris made a
new best friend
Dalton Lee Dalton was five - with severe
acne that lasted all the way into
adulthood okay he was smart but didn't
like school okay it was he appropriately
aged yeah he's a year there's a year
difference between okay he didn't get
along with his adoptive father who was a
doctor and a former war hero and Dalton
was obsessed with animals you just went
through what I'm going through right so
I was like
[Music]
hee hee on armadillos piranhas and
predatory birds including Falcon so you
can see how they met and it's like a
falcon get together where that's not
each boys go to talk about their Falcons
yeah and their previous owners and how
they died
don't dalton also like to use and sell
cocaine ok a lot of moving pieces in
this so far pieces he would give girls
cocaine for free until they were hooked
and then demand sex with them if they
wanted more when Dalton graduated from
high school he was making hundreds of
dollars a week and became a full time
drug dealer now at that point Chris had
just started his senior year every month
the two went to the desert to smoke weed
and fly Falcons isolate that's heart I
don't know why we're not doing that that
is something we should be doing
absolution without question hundred
percent that question and then we'll get
my van you know what 15 Home Depot's
away from our dream you grow your hair
long stop wearing shirts used to preach
another qualms with naman Chris once the
top student graduated in the BA bottom
third of his class what did you you
couldn't have anything to do with all
the wheat falconry oh come a little bit
a little bit to do with that interest he
went to junior college then he went to
Jesuit Lowell University but then in
1973 he said he was agnostic and dropped
out okay that fall he enrolled in Cal
Poly San Luis Obispo because it was
right next to a falcon sanctuary
why does he make go with the Falcons it
feels like the passion it really feels
like you see the Falcons go to school
here and what made you want to come in
you Falcons that's Mohammed I could talk
to it
that's mine Mohammed my best friend died
in a hash oil fire now my new best
friend's a cokehead where's the dorms
Chris started thinking about a career
traveling the world as an avian expert
but he dropped out of Cal Poly after one
year now his dad had worked at the FBI
before becoming a security expert for
airplane manufacturer McDonnell Douglas
okay he got Chris a job at TRW a defense
contractor in Redondo Beach Gerardus
here we go Orange County his job at TRW
was to quote push papers and sweep
floors but suni passed a quick pat oh
he's dead no he's dead that's a lot
cause soon he passed 70 passed all right
thanks everybody
[Music]
city passed a quote joke of a background
security investigation and the
department defense granted him a secret
security clearance you can see why
there's no red flags no no there's many
none of this guy is just a the perfect
American there's nothing about this guy
that doesn't say this is gonna go great
what's his clearance that is a super
secret well just he just got security
clearance but that's you know that's
your turn
no that's the action your term is super
secret no I didn't say super Ziegler
just a secret security clearance what a
big great oppose comes super secret
sorry you're just a super secret I'm a
lot more super Sam allowed to go in here
that's where Falcon on your shoulder
Sooni was brought into a mysterious room
at TRW called the black vault
what okay hey man you gotta check out
the black fall we're doing super secret
[ __ ] in here Christmas told TRW built
secret intelligence satellites for the
CIA okay the satellites beamed data to a
station at Pine Gap in Australia in
exchange for using the facility in
Australia the US had to share all
information gained with Australian
intelligence services all all
information everything they got from
these satellites because it was going
through Australia they had to share he
was there to give it all to Australia
okay right cuz we're allies we're
buddies
yes right sure
Chris's job was to decrypt the
information and they send it to the CIA
now while Chris was working Dalton was
becoming a huge heroin dealer
then we'd shaken his story a little bit
good I'm glad to see he's also
escalating things that's good so he's on
the outside doing this well chris is in
the black vault room and he went to jail
where he made a connection with the
Mexican Mafia
so his stories trending in the right
direction I mean you can see both these
guys are moving up in the yeah in a good
way yeah when he got out of jail dalton
became a middleman and he bought heroin
for the Mexican Mafia and then sold it
for profit to American drug dealers
everyone finds her after making drug
runs to Mexico he would throw massive
parties and pals faraday's that had
mounds of coke by the end of 1974 dalton
had become addicted to his own heroin
I'm shocked that that just happened that
feels like the gateway step in this life
how do you make it that far without
hunting the heroin one day I kinda shot
holy [ __ ] I was right oh I swear they
should sell it so whoa this is [ __ ]
awesome I'll do it all I get a nap
as Falcons are just eating his eyes
always like in January 1975 Crisler and
the CIA was using its secret satellites
to spy on China and the Soviet Union as
well as France and Israel who were
allies so he wasn't happy about that he
wasn't happy to learn that okay it's top
of that the CIA was violating its
contract by hiding this information from
the Australians okay oh and the CIA was
using the satellites to also spy on
Australian okay so feels Australia's
kind of caught in the middle you're like
we love all the information he gave me
guys yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] idiots
gonna love all the info so we're spying
on everybody including the place we're
like but you're our friend Yeah right
so Chris was very upset to learn this
quote I watched my government deceive an
ally who had fought next to us in two
world wars without giving up the
deliberation I deserved I decided to do
as much damage the American intelligence
community as I possibly could do I do
like the setup without really thinking
it all the way through
you can't put that genie back in the
bottle no once that's out it's out I
deleted the post so later that January
him and Dalton are doing cocaine cool
and he told Dalton about the black vault
he's not supposed to do that yeah super
secret yeah right you're not supposed to
tell your drug buddy yeah about the
spying that's going on yeah I would see
hopefully the best way to get secrets
out of someone in the CIA is cocaine
just like you have anything you want to
say like oh so much thanks but I can't
we killed Hendricks what did I say
[Applause]
Kennedy's alive I shouldn't do any more
Bill Clinton's actually a robot Oh oh
it's true
sex robot sex robots sorry I couldn't
get it all my mouth is so dry he's a sex
robot a week later Crist pitch to
daulton a plan
Chris would steal classified documents
is for sure on cocaine this plan this is
the plan that you do a line and you
stand up like ah here's what we can do
here we up I'll steal documents from the
CIA okay and then you'll go to the
Soviet embassy in a third country and
offer them for sale so you're gonna
you're gonna cuz you're coke dealers you
move around a lot so you'll go down to
Mexico and you just [ __ ] sell - this
is a perfect plan perfect plan [ __ ]
love this I love you - yes doing [ __ ]
yes this makes sense
don't let the hi stop otherwise we might
come to our senses so Chris have been
told by a fellow employee the Soviets
would pay 20,000 that's a weird an
employee by the way man this [ __ ] worth
20 grand to the enemy anyway I'm gonna
go Ronnie bar
Dalton was totally in he thought it was
a great idea the plan is to take these
secrets and go sell them to the Soviets
fake documents solve the Soviets get
cash not a great point oh that's a great
plan you get money yeah I don't know
what I'm not seeing anything wrong with
this okay that's interesting but at
march dalton sold cocaine to an
undercover cop I mean you got to pick
your partners yeah so he gets out of
bail I think it's on a bail in April and
his lawyer told them he could postpone
the trial for a while but eventually he
was gonna get a long prison sentence
so his lawyers keeping him out of jail
for a while so he's kind of gone like
runs Springer essentially right now
that's right so an early April Dalton
flew to Mexico carrying a stolen
document from the black vault now is
that against his probation that he's
probably I don't know that's okay to do
feels like it would be feels like that's
probably out yeah okay you're committing
treason is on the you know think you're
allowed to when you're waiting trial
Mexico City dogs snorted coke to get
some courage you try it
it totally works okay 100% right time to
courage to that courage 12 hours later
do you like God I'm glad I had that and
then he walked in to the Soviet embassy
and announced yet quote information
about spy satellites that's just
probably there's probably a way to do it
there's probably a way to walk in there
feeling I need to talk to someone you
don't just rail coke and then well I'm
gonna be like I've got CIA secrets baby
who's fired you have white on your nose
comrade ah so he had a meeting with KBG
agent Vasily O'Connor KGB agent Vasily
O'Connor okay doc told Vasily he had a
socialist friend who worked for the US
government and his friend had decided to
help the Soviets by giving them American
defense secrets and he expected to be
paid well in return
sure Dalton gave vasily the document and
vasily gave chris $250 and some vodka
first of all in russia that's $20,000
right second of all there's probably a
way to do this where you are actually
bartering it doesn't you don't give the
stuff and then be like what's your offer
you like half the stuff you like what
would you pay me that doesn't work for
me you know here it is that's too little
oh you have it I'll take a vodka sure
yeah that works
they scheduled a second meeting for
April 23rd
now Dalton then spent a few weeks in
Puerto Vallarta and then went back to
Mexico City for the second meeting with
facility okay but Dalton had no new
documents and just said the deliveries
would begin shortly okay well great to
see you again thank you for coming [ __ ]
off you're useless now in May Dalton got
a few black vault pages from Chris okay
and I'm 18th he gave them to vasily is
he looking for anything out of this deal
with Vasily don't know money yeah but
he's just like getting $200 so he's just
like going down there with papers like
here you go man what do you got awesome
ten dollars yeah
well they were just give him a taste
like he does with the women right okay
fair fair point just trying to get
bacilli hood yeah he literally compared
he thinks the dot yet he thinks his
documents are like getting someone
addicted he's it's the same mentality on
May 18th he gave them Mozilla to Vasili
in exchange for a few thousand dollars
all right two bottles are for me to bomb
yeah and some slow Gin yeah Vasili then
told Dalton how to set up future
meetings when he had more information
make an X at a white circle tape on a
lamppost that the Soviets watched and
then they would meet the next day at 6
p.m. at a location that have been
determined in the previous meeting sure
yeah
standard stuff yep just put an X on the
pole that the Soviets are studying and
then based on the last meeting you'll
know where the next meetings gonna take
place because they've noticed it that's
right pretty straightforward it's like a
Google Calendar in July Dalton gave
Vasily 20 pages of messages from Pine
Gap and he got more money okay they've
now received about $10,000 okay after
each meeting Dalton used his share of
the money to buy drugs from the Mex of
Mexican Mafia and then he would resell
it to u.s. drug dealers he would sell it
dog yeah he would he would take the
money and sell it yeah thank you
during a September meeting Dalton was
drunk good that's probably how you want
to enter those that's probably the best
one he had there they're like this new
gun he's put it be good these harsh
and he told Vasily everything he knew
about Chris's work at TR W oh Jesus
Christ he's that guy he's like a lane on
Seinfeld well I shouldn't okay well he's
also doing a bunch of other [ __ ] I
shouldn't really get it Jim have a lot
of fun you guys have a good time we put
the excellent rock poet so so sorry
oh [ __ ] okay I used to get a bad cuz
this is where I start spilling the beans
and I thought look okay not open me up
attach this Jew little bump see scooty
[Music]
better stuff but dog said his name he
didn't calm Chris he gave him an alias
oh that's nice Cristobal
what is his alias Cristobal crystal ball
Cristobal
Cristobal what'd he say Cristobal
Cristobal Cristobal like a crystal ball
were to be a person's name
yeah just say yeah yes yes crystal ball
crystal balls CR is TOB a.m. crystal
ball crystal it's very close to show
it's a short version that would be Chris
yes and I think that's very hard very
you're gonna be very hard for them to
decipher that yeah I mean that's Morse
essentially so back at Palos Verdes
Dalton started dropping hints about
making deals with Russia for CIA secrets
to his friends no you just shut up you
shut up you shut up
people dig secrets it's like when you
win the lottery you just shut up you
don't tell anyone you stay at your job
for four months you act like
everything's normal
meanwhile you're buying a [ __ ] house
in the Bahamas and then just one day you
leave everyone's like what happened you
never know your ghost otherwise you tell
over the lottery I'm gonna quit my job
oh man my medical bills you thought this
way too much everybody's thought this
this wondering if you win the lottery
you don't tell a person a [ __ ] thing
you don't show up for the big signing
with the cheque like 40 million dollars
you walk outside someone stabs you [ __ ]
my dick 140 about four dollars what for
the big check it can be cashed
it's got the endorsement line I don't
think you know what big checks are what
they what they do the guy who plays in
the small check pool and the role of
novelty size you kidding me but all all
Dongs friends assumed he was lying
that's what that's how you know you've
built up good cachet with your friends
when you're like revealing huge
government secrets and I like he's so
full of [ __ ] when a friend mentioned a
Robert Ludlum spy novel he was reading
Dalton said quote it's all real that guy
sorry what was that sorry oh all things
roll havin the friend the friend thought
Dalton had a small man complex
it's fight two in November Chris gave
you like the bagel boss guy
and November Chris gave Dalton four
rolls of film he said should be worth
$50,000 Chris gave that to Dalton yeah
okay so dog flew to Mexico City any
place an X on the lamppost okay but the
next day no one showed up over him well
he put it on the wrong lamppost okay
easy to do yeah he's really big on that
post lot of cocaine he did that probably
because he was actually high on cocaine
we sharpen up the axe for sure he had
been told to never go to the Soviet
embassy so he walked in to the Soviet
protocol and demanded a meeting yep you
just put the X on himself I have the
post find me but the film only had a few
negatives showing classified documents
okay most of them were photographs of
naked women
so in Chris's head he's like three
things of value and then just something
for the fellas I don't know yet naked
women in Russia they're just going
through it like useless useless totally
useless you say poor huh how you say
bone you just said it's good yes so
Dalton said Cristobal must have been
playing a joke and the annoying agents
gave Dalton $6,500 and he left it's
pretty good for an annoyed fee back in
Palos Verdes Crystal Dalton that the
photos were a joke from hustler magazine
they were gonna take my thumbs
good one good one
Dalton was [ __ ] furious but he also
said the look on the KGB agents faces
was priceless now I definitely like him
that's how you know he's got that sense
of humor you need for this business
he could have killed me dude but they
were for sure freaked out they were
gotcha in December a cop tried to pull
Dalton over for a burnt-out taillight
right you well he took off driving a
hundred miles an hour okay sure
didn't work they finally stopped him and
his fake driver's license said he was 5
inches taller than he actually was
that's a tough one
it's so hard when you're 5 2 and you get
a fake ID yeah I just want to be like
just 5 7 put your goal weight on there
you put your go away you're going high
you know your reaches I'm 5 7 with my
arms above my head officer they do that
at Six Flags they normally let me on all
the rides they're not dicks like you
guys they really don't and bailed
himself out with his drug money he
didn't tell the cops that though right
drug money yes let me ask ya for sure
his expensive legal team was still
getting his trials postponed dog kept
using cocaine and heroin because it's
going well ya know the combos working
well chris was suspecting that Dalton
was under paying him interesting and he
was right don't the way I was gonna say
Dalton was only giving him 20% of what
they were getting from the Soviets and
then Chris heard that two people had
died from heroin Dalton had been dealing
ok Chris started laying in bed at night
wondering quote is what I'm doing wrong
I just had assumed we'd already cross
that mortal bridge thank you is still
like god you're fine Chris drank it
would also fly his beloved Falcon pips
in the mountains with this due to get
drunk and fly up its Falcon in the
mountains tips the Falcon tips the
Falcon get [ __ ] hammered take tips up
to the mountain let that [ __ ] fly that
Falcon was like [ __ ] he's drunk hey you
wanna go around and get pips camera here
hello there pips they're going Mons
again I swear I'll hang here get up
tomorrow I wanna hang up my [ __ ]
armpits I'm driving we're on the
mountain we're both flying today [ __ ] ah
today's the day I get on your back
arrives you like Falkor
yeah so one story that ain't got an
ending today's the day when I can put
the saddle on your back and you fly me
up to God's house and then I get up
there and give him something secret
documents plus some hustler pictures of
jail all of us best friend you're the
best friend I know you don't give mom a
kiss don't get mom a kiss no one give
mom a kiss mom again Marcus mom kiss
your mama yeah hey let me feed you like
your mama did okay you like grilled
cheese remember the vet back
pips you complete me get you really big
astruc for when you find me up to heaven
you guys your six-pack work yeah I'm at
one more Bloody Mary then we're gonna
hit this [ __ ] understand we're going I
[ __ ] eat dead mice and your breath
smells worse I've been eating your
[ __ ] dead mice [ __ ] I've done
there's french fries last night when I
was hammered wait can you hear me huh is
is talking to you I don't you [ __ ] up
to drive you'll have to fly there
[Music]
so in March Dalton gave the Soviets
their biggest haul yet ten rolls of film
with highly classified documents at the
meeting dot was introduced to his new
KGB handler Boris well yeah sure a real
name right when Dalton arrived back in
LA he went directly to a party and
dramatically opened up his suitcase
$10,000 in $100 bills spilled out onto
the floor and Dalton said quote Uncle
Sam paid for it like arrest me is when
he's screaming please come arrest babe
at the next month's meeting Dalton gave
Boris and other agents a trove of
documents including one about a u.s.
submarine that was spying on Soviet
missile tests in the Arctic Jesus Christ
yep and Chris Chris's head he is doing
this in some capacity because he feels
like the government has not being honest
right and then on the other side of it
he's selling all this stuff for money
he's not like he's okay I mean there's a
moral situation sure yeah there's a
quandary yeah double standard
for all this information Dalton demanded
50,000 he said he was risking his life
and not getting enough quote if you
don't like the information and don't
start paying more we'll sell it to the
Chinese boom
their Embassy's over there
I'm gonna trick-or-treat with these two
secrets the agents were both silent and
then one asked quote you don't carry a
gun well that's a really weird follow up
dude
to what I just said Boris one why'd you
go to Boris to and say that you should
you sure to be more careful why that's a
threat so now Dalton was scared but he
felt he still had the power so he
demanded at least ten thousand dollars
and they gave it to him by the way
wouldn't your aunt wouldn't you just say
this yeah I did I got a foot sword but
it's crazy what's his shoe the things
broken it should have a sword coming out
of it at the next meeting in June the
Soviets treated Dalton very coldly and
then in July he was arrested for drunk
driving in Palos Verdes all the things
he did [ __ ] hurt someone man is drunk
driving the team I mean it's kind of
perfect yeah
I can't he bails himself out but he's
this is drug money by Chad Bono wait
that was some money to the Soviets sorry
I get mixed up with the drug money I
sell them secrets anyways she has a
month
so now Dalton is almost broke because
he's just spending all the money and all
his trials are coming up so I made a
plan but time machine he was gonna save
this money for the next few months and
then spend it all on one last drug buy
sell it make it ton move to Costa Rica
adorable what can go wrong well as we've
seen with this scenario
lots of stuff can go wrong not coming to
fruition at this time Chris decided he
wanted out he toyed with the idea of
taking Dalton out to the desert and
killing him yeah playing around with his
idea of shooting my friend
execution-style and a ditch he digs guy
had a weird thought the other day I'm
not gonna goof but he decided that
wouldn't solve this problem so that's
nice that's why yeah that's not the
Silver Bullet I'm looking for comes up
with a new plan say Kim comes up the new
plan to talk to us Soviets himself and
tell them he wanted out does he need to
do this we felt like you had no other
option he felt that he is like he's not
that implicit I mean I guess he is kind
of tied up in it but not as much as
Dalton Dalton superin is so I feel like
he could just roll but if the steadies
gonna go there and take a meeting
yeah gotta quit face to face yeah he's a
man of honor
you guys replying my messages so I
thought I'd come do this person this is
my two weeks after this I've done
so he crystallized at Mexico City in
October he and Dalton decided on a whim
that they wanted to meet the Russians
never on a whim
don't took him to meet Boris by the way
is code for cocaine on a windowpane they
decided to go meet the Russians whatever
so Dalton took him to meet Boris on a
public street and they were then taken
into a limo to the Soviet man the street
feel like Oh we'll get in the car for
sure yeah that's that's absolutely okay
yeah they were they taking to live up to
the Soviet embassy where Chris was
greeted warmly and thank for helping the
socialist cause they were given a
Russian feast [ __ ] mice and the potato
put the mouse in the potato
make a hole make hole the mouse will run
into it and then shelter for Chris hated
the food so much he wonder if he had
been poisoned that is actually a really
dicey thing to have happen in Russia
right if you don't like the food you're
probably I've been poisoned I can't
bring that up I think they poison
god I hope it's just a shitty meal
like you would maybe Boras ask Chris
detailed questions about the black vault
but a trunk Daulton kept butting in then
Boris got super-drunk sure and then
Morris and Dalton gone to an argument
and almost came to blows sure and then
they come back down down and after a
while pours proposed an idea Dalton
would make one final delivery in January
and Chris would quit his job at TRW and
the Soviets would pay for Chris to get a
college degree this is the drunken
espionage plan ever thought they might
get their scholarship
[Applause]
they sponsor guys kind of okay so to
finalize negotiation
you make one more trip you quit and then
you're going to go through Harvard okay
we gotta dress pretty normal
Dalton you get shot in drunk
Jill go back you go okay all right well
the idea was to have Chris get a college
degree and then join the CIA after he
graduated to become a soviet mole well
there it is
Baroness you want out we say you go
deeper yeah okay sure
Chris thought we might as well take the
opportunity to get a free education yeah
yeah for sure how to look at this can i
major in anything
no major specifically and what we tell
you he figured he could cut ties with
the Soviets after he graduates you're
absolutely just have a sit down sit put
an X on your chest have a sit-down with
the souks just tell him look I'd love to
I mean college was so great though I
really made a bunch of friends I think I
want to be a vet just good to help
someone out so Chris said yes to the
plan and when he got home he started
applying to colleges
okey-dokey now don't reason for going oh
that's a tough one that's loaded that
Dalton needed money using some strips of
film strips he he'd gotten from Chris
months earlier I guess he'd kept them
cool good he went back to Mexico City
but Dalton was not supposed to come
again until his final delivery in
January yeah he put an X on the lamppost
she says Christ the next day at 6 p.m.
Boris did not show up
so Dalton walked right into the embassy
this dude needs to stop treating the
embassy like cheers is just rolling in
like a regular which was born for Sam I
know I didn't need to put the time out
favorite Americans here what's up yeah
you guys want some blow Boris was [ __ ]
in furious don't just pulled out the
film right there and said give me
$10,000 Boris that had to Embassy
employees drag Dalton to the limousine
to take him on a limo run drag to the
limos fun after 50 minutes the limo
slowed and Dalton was pushed out the
door as it moved
that's when you know you're on top he
was shaken but he was not injured
meanwhile Chris was accepted to UC
Riverside seeing both sides of the coin
huh they just threw me out of a limo oh
I'm going to Arizona State yeah
hey Matt so Chris not needed Dalton to
make the final delivery and Dalton said
after what had happened the delivery was
a bad idea he left out the part where he
went to Mexico got pushed out of a
moving limo oh he was just like I kind
of had an awakening of sorts I don't
think they're cool anymore
they're the kind of guys that are
dragged into a limo and she'll be out of
it 15 feet later he said to Chris quote
it's getting spooky because of him Chris
said the photos were worth at least
75,000 and that's when dolls like are we
can do it that's yeah yeah altogether
they now had gotten seventy seven
thousand dollars from the Soviets
dad on January fourth Dalton got his
trial date it was going to be on January
20th so we are leaving the queue yeah
right so now now we got it we got a
ticking clock yeah
his final meeting with the Soviets was
set for January 5th this is perfect and
the guy he was going to buy the drugs
from in the Mafia Mexican Mafia that
that day was on January 7 okay so we've
got a problem he's got two days to get
the money
oh so it's fine yes okay Jerry fifth in
January seventh okay so Dalton boarding
a plane to Mexico and the negatives he
did not intend to return to Mexico so
his plan was to take the money and just
[ __ ] bail okay but Boris did not show
up at 6:00 p.m.
again with the drug Buy lined up two
days later Dalton had to make this
happen so he's drunk he's drunk and he's
high on coke you know do you do it
sir you just stay where you are as he
walks up to the Soviet and in that
direction
no that's where he just leave a note put
a post-it on the door that's now the
gate was closed good staying there so he
tore the cover off his Spanish English
dictionary what KGB on it crumpled it up
and threw it through the gate
[Laughter]
surely there's better things to write
what he's like like you're asking for a
friend to come play did you become on
preferably not Boris he's been a real
dick an embassy employee picked it up
but a Mexican cop was watching this and
he rushed over to question dong dongs
got it was through his dictionary like
hold on a second lo siento
sangria yeah Tortuga sorry no this I
don't want Saint turtle
Dora
he was very indignant and he said he was
an American tourist and he just threw
away some trash that's how we like to
talk to him when we go abroad - that's
how I'm an American it's trash leave me
alone
the French really are [ __ ]
and the cop was about to let him go the
cop was like this guy's just a drunk you
so this hop is horrible well then he
noticed Daulton had dropped a joint and
was trying to hide it under his foot
I've been there let's add something to
where you've been what if you're giving
a message to the Soviets yes
what if at that point you don't smoke a
joint well if I may push back go ahead
he's drunk so counterpoint a joint feels
really good right now
at the police station dalton said the
filmstrips in his pockets were for a
commercial he was shooting and now in
the craziest coincidence of all he had a
postcard in his pocket and the postcard
was a picture of an intersection and at
that intersection a week earlier a
Mexican cop had been killed by Mexican
communists so the cops were now
convinced that he was involved in the
murder of another cop and I swear to God
I thought that was gonna go one of two
ways I thought they're gonna be like
that's so nice that you recognize that
instead like you did this come over here
no I'm just telling secrets I'm so
sacred
he didn't right kid you be on the
postcard yes yes yes and not normal
still the next day Chris called Dalton's
hotel and found out he had been arrested
Chris decided it was time to face the
consequences On January 10th knowing he
would be arrested soon he started school
and UC Riverside's wait sorry so his
plan is to keep going still the syllabus
and go from there you see what you know
you want to experience college life for
a couple days yeah yeah well I may have
a week of freedom I think I'm ready to
go to school
I really do I think I'll stay here
meanwhile the cops in Mexico were
interrogating a suspected cop murderer
Dalton and the brutality was increasing
he was beaten he was forced to drink
untreated water which made him get
diarrhea and then they pushed his head
into the diarrhea filled toilet that's
right at the bacteria I mean that's just
like that's what was like growing up in
my house yeah
On January 14th Dalton was turned over
to the FBI he was like thank God but he
then told a mostly true version of the
previous few years but he downplayed how
much money he made and how often he'd
met the soviets and he said Chris told
them they were working as subcontractors
for the CIA and we're purposely feeding
the KGB false intelligence yet so it
works normally that you find someone
who's in the CIA adjacent and they bring
a friend yeah yes a drug dealer friend
and that's how you guys do it quote I
got it to this to screw the Russians
dude up with you guys I wanna you give
me the badge
we're on the same side guys a January
16th Chris's car was swarmed by FBI
agents outside his Riverside house he
was handcuffed by an agent who screamed
quote do you know what you're charged
with espionage where are the documents
you [ __ ] traitor
Pitts Muhammad attacked
you know the story you know the story
the FBI agents were attacked by
thousands of families their friends from
the hills eagles are even coming Oh
Birds United for the cause crows Ravens
vultures eagles falcons Ravens pigeons
doves Dodos
or cops murdered by all the birds in the
state shocking twist tonight at 11:00 at
the FBI's LA headquarters crystal agents
quote politically a very disenchanted
with this government it's done many
things wrong and then he told him the
entire story and when he was finished he
said quote whole thing's been a
nightmare actually wait I want my lawyer
[ __ ] I did that the wrong order his
trial began on April 12 1977 in Los
Angeles the federal prosecutor said
Chris was responsible for the biggest
breach of security in America since
World War two the trial also included
the CIA's first public admission that it
was using secret spy satellites the
right which might be the story whoa it's
that they're like you broke the law let
them take the secrets from the world you
dick the reveal of a CA presence at Pine
Gap calls cause a media firestorm on
Australia the CIA's deception led to a
diplomatic crisis between the u.s. and
Australia now under oath Chris lied and
said it all started when he gave a
letter to Dalton about America deceiving
Australia hoping to be a whistleblower
Chris claims dalton promised to give the
letter to a friend in the media but
instead he sold it to the soviets and
then he blackmailed Chris to do
everything else that's a pretty good
line right that's pretty good I bet yeah
not bad
the jury found Chris guilty of espionage
not a great light not a great
not convincing espionage and conspiracy
to commit espionage in may Dalton was
found guilty of the st. charges while in
jail awaiting sentence and sentencing
Chris considered suicide and made a new
set of his pants before he backed out he
should have tried it's real easy to do
it I know any way at all like how far
can you get anybody can do it okay the
guards take three hour breaks it's kind
of cool Shelley and sleepy guards and
then you're totally fine that the the
just a couple of our last four
presidents hanging out with Dave how'd
you stop eating a psychopath okay Jesus
Christ right it's like hanging out with
Twitter out of your mind he was just a
one-man machine just two out of four
presidents he's hanging out with Rick oh
yeah picture port a port painted
portrait of Bill Clinton in the Monica
Lewinsky dress in his fly yay you think
that's weird never looks like what what
he did it's fine I've seen had a
painting of Bill Clinton sitting on an
ottoman leaning sideways
he looks my mother relevance in the
Monica Lewinsky dress yeah look if he
looks good in it though so it's not
weird
totally normal [ __ ] goes attractive
totally normal attractive and a
photograph of trumps bubble yes and it's
Erin
I filled the Orange County separation
line anyway jail so he backs out he
decides not to kill himself
Dalton was sent to life in prison Chris
got 40 years he got a lighter sentence
because Dalton had all the prior because
he was just a dalton they were like well
he for sure for life and you're like
half as [ __ ] as him for me can I finish
my blow y-yeah yes I guess I mean this
guy's out of his mind yes Oh love courts
you guys want to talk about some stuff
okay but stenographers hand fell off can
we send him out of here
so with good behavior they both would be
eligible for parole around 1995 dot was
sent to prison in Lompoc and chris to a
prison in San Diego I took San Diego
over a long pokken without question the
1979 Robert Lindsay published a book
about Chris and Dalton titled the Falcon
and the snowman
dynamite dynamite title have you seen
the movie what have you seen the movie
are you [ __ ] with me are you big
serious serious no we're watching the
movie will record audio the Falcon and
the snow yes [ __ ] great the way that
is totally a movie my mother would rent
for me when I was like eight and I'd be
like I don't think I should be watching
this camera just picked out your
stiffies doing with all that snow
I'm seven that's cocaine I don't know
what to tell you I am the Falcon and the
snowman that year click Beauty and the
Beast
welcome and the snowman it's actually
very different name one difference that
same year Chris was transferred to
Lompoc
oh he in Dalton initially butted heads
and went at it but eventually they
calmed down and then they started
spending hours together playing chess
and drinking contraband alcohol and
letters to a friend Chris wrote quote
these were not the prison's of a
civilized society and says his hatred
for America was affirmed without really
[ __ ] mad cuz this prison is [ __ ]
but it's like like the first part like
his initial anger you're like yeah I get
that like I could understand me like
that's [ __ ] up everything since then
it's been illegal and wrong he's that
every part of it wrong so now he's in
jail for like breaking the law and weird
ways he's like man I told you this
country sucks
he can't even been espionage anyways
publicly one day in the yard
Chris noticed a tiny gap at the foot of
the guard tower shut up these two all
right
this is their like a sitcom their bosom
buddies that's what they are the only
thing between the yard and total freedom
was a 10 foot tall chain-link fence oh
is that all Chris came up with an escape
plan run over the fence
he asked Dalton to join him in dalton
said quote you got me in enough trouble
already I don't need you or anyone else
to save me you'll get yourself killed
Dalton has really become the Chris of
the Dalton Chris yeah Chris responded
quote I'm already dead and then he
looked at the prison window dramatically
dips
Oh tips it's your dad it's Chris don't
have any rope myself dude
that bird [ __ ] hates you mad I didn't
want to say this a long time ago but
that dude he thinks you're a [ __ ]
dick his dad died in Nam man he's like
he thinks what you're doing is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I guess I shouldn't have renamed him
tips either yeah that was funny
Mohammed yeah dude was dudes full-on
Muslim and then you're like hey your
name's pips hipsters cute
very Muslim no a little name so they
they into screamed Escape from Alcatraz
in the prison a few months earlier
cannot be true that cannot be true it's
true how is that true that's true
that's like showing flight 93 on
American Airlines
who is the warden who's like you know
what we need is to challenge the guys we
really got to put something ahead of
them for them to run after Escape from
Alcatraz always like sapphire into
prisoners asses that's what all the
spoons go missing on January 21st 1980
Chris place a dummy in his bed that you
miss Dalton and then and then he hid in
a shallow hole that he'd dug in the yard
that was hard for me this yard
everyone's everyone's in the yard
hanging out doing prison yard stuff and
there's a guy over there digging a hole
okay york times over like i just lays
down he's big if you just say you're
making dirt castles it's totally
different
you got to get the dirt from somewhere
so after dark so he waits it gets dark
and then he sneaks over the chain-link
fence
climbs over that being spotted and off
he goes wow that was really easy I went
to college and I remember if you look
the Russian was sent here why I went to
college I was closed up to Lompoc then
they talked about there were guys
escaping from there all the [ __ ] time
as I recall but anyway
he he survived on berries and insects
for a few days until he reached a town
with a good smell - then he spent weeks
in the hills stealing food at night from
houses eventually he hitchhiked to a
remote spot on the Canadian border and
then he walked across and then
immediately crossed back quote as if
reeled in by some imperceptible tether
he could bring himself to leave America
look you can't just go to the border and
run suicides you've gotta like to me
patriotism out of it okay if you're
saying one country is gonna put me in
jail and the others not I have a new
favorite country that's the one that
won't put me in jail doesn't know about
me that's my new one yeah
Teddy's just so-so go back to eating
bugs and berries in the hills stealing
bread loaves from window sills he
settled into Bonners Ferry Idaho it's
what we talked about earlier I'm a
boarder in 20 miles south just 20 miles
off the border he used the name Jim
name-check
so clearly someone was like what's your
full name and he was like Jim name-check
its coach he got a job at a farm he
rented a cabin
he bought a mule Mohammed and he became
friends with some local ex-cons and
outlaws perfect just looking for a new
crew he started helping them run a
marijuana growing operation good good
the whole time he's very open about his
actual identity and would even tell
random loggers at bars about his
adventures he's got a case of the
Daltons and I hated on more than one
occasion while trying to convince a
skeptic he man he pulled out a copy of
the Falcon and the snowman is so douchey
so douchey but northern Idaho is a big
area for outcasts with strong
anti-government settlement settlements
not see the few people who believe
Chris's stories never went to the cops
watch a Griffith 1980 chris robbed a
bank in a Spokane Washington have you
guys met the guy who's way too into it
he's right there six lazy days later he
dropped another Bank this time dude is
just playing on house money I mean
you've gotta like got to make some money
yeah what's he gonna do we're gonna form
yes
so this time he was photographed by a
security camera but FBI agents did not
recognize the bearded man with the low
baseball cap he started running with
companions some accomplices and they
robbed several more banks in Washington
I know I'm in Montana that summer it's
September
he told the hills brothers three men who
robbed some banks with him that they
should enroll in the army then with
Chris's help they could steal military
secrets and re-establish so he's just
trying to live his life twice and then
he could they could contact the Soviets
and they pay for them don't worry I know
abort oh I know which pull detects
[Music]
thousands of tips and alleged sightings
of Chris port into law enforcement but
none were ever accurate investigators
became convinced that Chris had left the
country they spare a minute they spent
millions of dollars chasing rumors in
South Africa Costa Rica Australia and in
other countries fall came and there was
still not a single reliable sighting
investigators starting to think Chris
was dead in the forest around
of president christen the hills kept
robbing banks I said it on October 23rd
nine months after he escaped Chris got
drunk at a bar in Montana
here we go and called the Falcon and the
snowman our author Robert Lindsey was
way over what was happening there was
who is this okay buddy this is yes sorry
this is this Falcon man miss Chris Boyce
buddy oh hello
the Snowman is not here you know sit
here bro huh like your book all right
well I should go it's just been great
fire away man asking questions ya know
that no fire way all right fire away all
right I'm trying to make another call
can you know I know who it is I've tried
to hang up so I just tried to hit the
thing where I do the clicky so I'm gonna
click it up yeah try to make an outgoing
call yeah yeah so just if you hang up
cuz I won't hang up on you that's the
problem here
okay hang it up hanging up there's no
dial tone which indicates
they're very funny very good way lassic
Falcon how are you that's how I am I
gotta go bye buddy
KGB okay you know the brothers the
chicken of the operation man ice enough
so you're gonna have to rename the next
one would be the hills and really good I
am going for sure I'm better you're
gonna make that other call so [ __ ] up
Idaho is so weird
you shouldn't be saying these things but
I they talked for a while and Chris
would not say where he was but he had so
our resin it's not really accurate
Jackie that's weird he said he had quote
never been happier he denied rumors that
the CIA or KGB had helped him escape
call proved he was still alive but law
enforcement had no clue where he was in
December Chris and the Hills brothers
moved to Olympic Peninsula in Washington
and Chris started going by Shawn Anna
see nice upgrade right then on December
23rd Chris called his cousin to wish her
a Merry Christmas asked her to tell his
parents that he loved them the call
could not be traced by Sprint 1981 Chris
had a plan I can't dude is not stopping
he was gonna fly a helicopter
into the yard at Lompoc prison and break
Dalton now he told the guards might see
it he told the friend quote Dalton is
not any more innocent than I am but that
doesn't change the fact he's in prison
because of something I started after
breaking out the plan was that they
would take a boat to Alaska and then
Russia yep
you can see it from there so Chris kept
robbing banks every few weeks to pay for
the helicopter in this neighborhood
they're like oh [ __ ] Tim again he was
trying to pay for the helicopter lessons
I'm shocked he's taking lessons that is
shocking in July
Kate Mills became Dalton's new lawyer
she later said Dalton was quote clinging
to Chris as the embodiment of his
earthly woes and then he referred to
crisp only as quote my co-defendant
later that month Chris drove too long
hope to scout his breakout plan laid it
right next that hole that dug which
shouldn't still be there it's a
three-part plan I will get the
helicopter and then get it on the ground
and then we'll go scouting he spotted
Dalton to the fence and recognized him
because of his two-handed tennis swing
can you imagine
let's my boy I'd recognize that
two-handed backhand anyway you look very
different but your backhands to say are
you imagine going back to the jail you
broke out of a peeking through the fence
I mean why just feel like they're not
good at Lompoc no they're not but still
you know let's you do not do that no you
know Andy Dufresne didn't go back to
Shawshank like that's where they beat
the [ __ ] out of me oh [ __ ] they saw me a
few days later a hook record reporter
named Guy Blake called Kate sang had
information that could help Tom the two
met in a parking lot in Santa Barbara
Blake was acting strange yeah and was
clearly wearing a fake mustache so he's
pulling the deep throat hi I'm Debra so
Kate told Blake to quote cut the
[ __ ] put him in it's just a regular
mustache that doesn't fit my face
properly Blake said quote I'll ask you
to pass something to him but it's
mustache give it to him tell him to wear
this and walk out the door he'll know
what to do it's a cop mustache but right
as he was saying that headlights of a
police cruiser for Cruiser flashed in
the window but the time the cop got out
of the car to tell him the parking lot
was closed
Blake guy Blake had vanished into the
night huh his mustache like the feather
the next day Kate called the Lompoc
record have found out they did not have
a reporter named guy Blake I knew it
Yeah right on July 31st one of Hills
brothers met with a US Marshal he wanted
the $250,000 reward for Chris and he
said Chris was living on the Olympic
Peninsula agents went to a store at Port
Angeles Washington where the hill
brothers said Chris bought paint sure no
questions
they found two receipts with Chris's
handwriting and after 18 months this was
the first evidence tying Chris to a
location in August Chris came back to
Washington to resume helicopter lessons
on August 21st 1981 exactly 19 months
after his escape Chris was eating a
burger in his car outside a diner when
he was spotted by US Marshal that's a
crazy move right off the bat diamond or
get it to go but car eating in front of
the joint what are you out of your mind
I just like to eat it and watch the
people inside to pretend they're my
friends
floo call the cops
there's a [ __ ] madman out there
eating a goddamn hamburger in his car
look at him he's waving it that guy's a
[ __ ] psycho
I mean eat in or go well I'm gonna eat
the Buster back at home
holy [ __ ]
when US marshals pulled up they ordered
him to quote drop the hamburger when the
marshal who handcuffed Chris called him
by his real name Chris a holding
hamburger you drop to him
it's an American standoff so they
handcuffed him and they called them by
his real name and Chris said quote it's
been a long time since anyone called me
that Chris was sent to federal a federal
penitentiary in Kansas and put in
solitary confinement
yeah so I'll take environments [ __ ]
yeah for anybody it shouldn't be three
years were added to his sentence and 25
were added for the 17 bank robberies
he'd committed he would be eligible for
parole after 20 years in exchange for
their cooperation the hill brothers were
not prosecuted for the bank robberies
and were only given 50,000 of the reward
it's pretty good 1985 the Falcon and the
snowman was released in theaters Chris
was played by Timothy Hutton Dalton was
played by Sean Penn holy [ __ ] I can't
believe you've never seen it 1985 yeah
three months later Chris testified
before the US Senate during hearings but
the government security clearance system
he gave eight recommendations for
preventing a spying situation like his
own and he and his testimony quote I
only wish centers that before more
Americans take that irreversible step
that they could know what I know now
that they are bringing down upon
themselves heartache more heavy than a
mouth don't bow sorry it was just really
good it was not don't bow in my court
don't curtsy halfway like that either
whatever you
doing that gesture no quality ending
sitters okay top no I'm just kidding he
left me so that is the move if he pulled
if what the move Chris by like talk
going to the Senate and recommending
like things to do like that's the
movement people hold when this all
started
baby has an impact yeah now it's now
they're like yeah you're out of your
mind though you robbed 17 banks so we
are not in 1988 he was moved out of
solitary so that means he was in
solitary just seven years which defines
his torture so he went to a prison in
Minnesota he got a boy did he have stuff
to talk about and then this other time
this guy he had a degree in history
while in prison on July 22nd 1997 with
the help of Kate Mills Dalton was
released from Lompoc on parole he had
been in prison for 20 years he was 45
years old he briefly became Sean Penn's
personal assistant
[Applause]
oh my god that's a [ __ ] movie that is
another good bit Sean Penn and the
Snowman
that's a movie act that you hear that
you're like [ __ ] shut pens cool he's
out of his mind he's out of his mind
he's out of his mind briefly so was that
meeting today all right this is not
you're not ready to be on the scene no
Kate been focused on freeing Chris and
Kate Chris became close and a romantic
relationship development
she also remained friends with Dalton
but Dalton was very jealous of their
relationship
classic snowmen in 2000 Dalton convinced
Kate to open a restaurant with him in
San Francisco you like chicken I like
chicken no yeah I'm a lawyer you're an
ex-con let's do this when she realized a
funder was a drug dealer she backed out
but all the guys I know with money yeah
except for the Soviets I don't [ __ ]
thing went to [ __ ] Dalton then wrote her
letter quote ask a GP and threw it over
[Applause]
well a scathing note on what a complete
[ __ ] I was she never saw Dalton again
there is no publicly available
information about Dalton's whereabouts
after 2000 he's here tonight September
16 2002 Chris was released on parole
from a prison in Oregon he's 49 years
old later that day he proposed to Cape
st. quote I've loved you ever since I
saw you in that Beach parking lot that
was the first time he admitted that he
had been guy played the reporter guy
Blake who's his name before Jim
name-check Stern is not ready for the
alias game I spent one minute in Canada
I was Mountie Mike and then I came back
in October they married and they settled
in Oregon Chris got a job as a manager
at an airport do we have access to
helicopters at the airport in a 2013
interview he said that while he
regretted spying he felt worse about the
bank robberies
don't let Chris had not spoken since
January 20th 1980 the day before Chris
escaped from prison on May 15th 2019 an
anonymous wikipedia user made seven
edits to Chris boys's article these are
the only edits this user ever made on
Wikipedia the first two edits out of the
information that Chris was now estranged
from Kade and hates restaurants the
editor then added the following sentence
quote Boise is also on good terms with
his father and eight siblings and his
mother until her death in 2017 the
editor then removed all mentions of
Chris's current whereabouts the article
had stated he was living in Oregon
finally the letter changed a single
letter so that the sentence quote he had
resumed his participation in falcon
falconry how red he has resumed
[Applause]
ride he took us on their Muhammed that
one is breathing it's such a California
crying like he's yeah he's not a
whistleblower he's a guy who had a
whistle in his mouth and never blew
he's a whistle holder he's back with
awesome that making was estranged when
we did that episode on that guy who got
his arms ripped off listen harvester and
then he like iced them and then he like
had a great sense of humor and he like
got his arms reattached and we did the
story on that and then that dude emailed
us was like
[Applause]
it's like imagine well thank you guys so
much for coming
[Applause]
[Music]